gagner pour se rapprocher du haut du
classement ce dimanche 2 juillet les
Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
recevait le leader de la poule Stade
Toulousain après avoir remporté la
première partie la veille sur le score
de 7 à 2 les inhymontins n'ont pas
réussi enchaîner lors de cette seconde
partie trop brouillon il s'incline sur
le score de 10 à 3 on a pas manqué de
grand chose si on a manqué peut-être un
petit peu de frappe mais ce qui a
vraiment été
négatif aujourd'hui c'est la défense on
a fait quelques erreurs et du coup dans
des matchs de haut niveau comme ça ça
pardonne pas donc malheureusement
prendre des points assez bêtement là
dessus
on a joué hier et on joue le lendemain
c'est pas évident pour le corps faut
pouvoir le remettre dedans et des en
défense qui nous mettent je pense
mentalement un peu au fond
et on n'a pas réussi à se relever
malheureusement on l'a déjà fait on sait
le faire et on espère le faire pour
la fin après ce bilan d'une victoire et
une défaite sur ce week-end au stade
Jean maréchal les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux pointe à la
troisième place de la poule avec un
bilan de 12 victoires pour huit défaites
donc là il va falloir qu'on a jusqu'au
bout des choses il y aura pas le choix
il va falloir tenir jusqu'à la fin de
saison là on peut potentiellement aller
chercher les playoffs si on gagne tous
nos matchs après si on en perd un ça va
être ça dépend de résultat des autres
donc là ça va être plus compliqué
prochaine rencontre pour les Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce dimanche 9
juillet il joueront contre les
boucaniers de La Rochelle les deuxièmes
du classement
[Applaudissements]